[Music]
recently we covered an article about
some Ukrainian douchebags beating up
their neighbor right the old lady oh
that was crazy
and they buried her alive yeah well I
was here for you weren't here yet so
yeah quick recap you can check out that
video Ukranian bad guys said hey
neighbor you're been mean to us and they
put that bet bet and then they took her
and buried her alive the image she loved
she [ __ ] broke out of that [ __ ]
climbed out and she took a map when she
got home he also made her dig her own
grave yeah be here for hours broke her
ribs like her jaw oh I wanted to see the
other guys cuz she looked like a
football player yeah she looked up she
put up a fight huh for sure she looks
like she digs deep so then they get
arrested or anything what happened you
got arrested okay this is an update
boilers this is not an update this is a
this is a Chinese remake so now imagine
Chinese lady beat the shells and doing
stabbed over
yeah the dubbed over exactly they've
been recasted all together so instead of
the two Ukrainian bad guys it's a
Chinese son
it's an all-asian cast it's nice all
agent can the son beat up the mom he
didn't do the beating up because the mom
didn't need to be immobilized through
violence the mom is a paralyzed mom Oh
any barrier oh yeah oh I was gonna be
like house how is she gonna dig her own
grave as she's paralyzed
she couldn't he didn't follow the script
she's just sick overly if she army
crawled out no she got rescued three
days later so it's a happy story for
three days she was calling for help and
I mean Oh actually the wife the wife was
like where's where's your mama and then
eventually they were able to track it
down and find the burial place and they
they dug her back up and there's a video
of this is why I feel like okay I don't
think this is working out
if you're willing to do this your mom
how bad are these criminals of burying
people I don't know that's [ __ ] four
three two what did she eat oh my gosh we
got a litter like that and then she was
just buried without any structure around
her
I don't think oh the emo not a graveyard
you breathe sounds hello northern
Chinese almost like Mongolian oh [ __ ]
yeah this is definitely like a very
rural area she does move a little bit
she's like partly paralyzed so but you
can see that she's a lot of people
bearing people so like what and his
killer the protocols in America compared
to other countries they just lift her up
hella crazy put a rag over her and just
left her there what do you want to do
with her and I think what do we do now
deep [ __ ] yeah one son dug that up
and buried is my like hell nobody was
like hey lady you alright they're just
like oh god yeah this is crazy let's
just cover up in the blanket what do you
guys want to do Bob Bob Chinese Bob
Chinese
Bao hey pal what the hell man so
apparently the son who's 58 years old
58 mm-hmm so the mom is 79 yeah yeah she
should have she was probably nagging too
much yeah that's what I was thinking
perhaps or maybe the son just being a
dick and doesn't want to tend to his
paralyzed mom and Don you know what
maybe if I just killed her but you don't
know how nagging some ladies can be true
and then you gotta wipe her ass yeah oh
this is [ __ ] crazy like she stayed
alive at how old is she
79 no water no food for three days
[ __ ] straight she deserves to survive
dude no coffee no yeah no I could never
as my grandma had Alzheimer's right and
as she was constantly complaining and
since I was just there to visit I hear
in there I thought it was super funny
now that was really enjoyable and
charming
but I looked at like the look on my mom
who's been taking care of her for a
couple of years and then just like the
24-hour help that they hired I'm like
damn I can see why people just throw
like throw some and then like a senior
home cuz it's just non-stop complaining
over and over and over and over again
especially with Alzheimer's they don't
even know what they're we have no
awareness not just the complaining man
there's just other things too like if
they [ __ ] poopoo themselves or if
there's like they wake up in the middle
of the night and turn on the stove and
start cooking or like there's a lot of
fun injuries yeah yeah cuz when my
grandma was getting that stuff like we
try to keep her in the house as much as
possible but [ __ ] goes crazy man yeah my
grandma would be sitting there and she's
like oh [ __ ] I need a [ __ ] and in Seoul
so she's not paralyzed so that we have
these two like like caretakers they come
and immediately grab her hurry hurry cuz
she's not gonna she's a flesh and to
make sure on that toilet okay so she's
like very I'm gonna [ __ ] myself and then
how could he do the the bathroom I think
she has an episode she was like what the
[ __ ] are you guys and so she pushes him
off she doesn't even she falls on the
ground because she pushed the mommy a
drunk needed a [ __ ] she falls on the
ground starts crying cuz I got hips are
all weak whatever just starts crying
they should does [ __ ] herself because
the body is still biological the body
still remembers yeah did you forget yes
so she [ __ ] herself and then her she
cook comes back and she goes how can you
guys just abandon the old lady on the
ground like this and let me [ __ ] myself
though she forgot then the workers were
just like oh my god and then now they
gotta carry her back in and I'm just
looking yeah I'm just looking at like
the whole city to me it's funny as [ __ ]
cuz I'm watch from the outside yeah when
I watch my mom and like just the amount
of yeah it's just like oh so I can I can
like my mom is with at my grandma's
house at the end of the day when like
it's like 7 or 8 she goes back to her
house in Taiwan and she finally goes oh
my gosh [ __ ] that's and it's their old
mom I think it's easier when you're the
grandkid yeah when it's
Oh mom I don't know it was pretty hard
for me when my grandma got Alzheimer's
because she's a young grandma so she's
always been like way younger and cool
others used to borrow my clothes and
stuff grab up all your clothes yeah
she's 44 when I was born and so she was
like young and hip and like she'd always
try to barter with me she'd be like what
if I trade you my jeans for those
reasons I'm like geez these are
expensive grandma and she's like oh you
little [ __ ]
Oh seal this and she's like is she's fun
and then she just lost her mind like she
got Alzheimer's really early yeah it's
like you had two moms yeah and then she
would like the eating dog [ __ ] and then
you're like doh where'd she get dog food
like she had dogs and then like she
would randomly like go have an episode
she was like she like you see this and
she'd start eating it if you like don't
don't eat that she like for me I don't
know you know like my grandpa would try
to stop her because she trusted my
grandpa
she always think that I was trying to
hit on my grandpa I try to steal him
from her and and she also was in love
with my brother and like all of her
grandkids sons she was like kind of a
flirt when she was younger and so she in
her mind she's high school-aged that's
why she wanted her clothes
she's like you see these boys they're
mine I got dibs on them that's cute at
the same time and then she thought my
dad was trying to steal everything from
her house cuz he was brown that's so
[ __ ] funny
Alzheimer's is crazy man I don't know if
she saw me is definitely a threat though
that I was trying to steal her man and
like cuz I came with my brother too and
she's like that's mine she's like I got
dibs already how this was happening it
started when she was I think like before
her 60th birthday she was young man and
it happened like where we didn't realize
that she had Alzheimer's like she cuz at
first she was just forgetting things she
was just telling the same story over and
over like so old people [ __ ] yeah like
my mom does that like I do that
sometimes Steve [ __ ] does that
yeah we're like whatever that Sanjay kid
knew the whole time yeah exactly
so then I wasn't big deal but then she
started like forgetting people's names
and that wasn't a big deal either cuz
that happens if you had I'd do it now
kids and then she started forgetting
words like actual words for things like
where she would call like the shoe like
hey I gotta get my clowns and they were
like what are you talking about she
liked my clowns my clowns and then she
liked clowns and then we're like that's
a shoe and she'd get embarrassed cuz
then she'd remember that that's not what
it was called and then it happened she
was just yelling at her home reflection
saying that there was an old lady in the
bathroom that was like oh [ __ ] stealing
all her stuff and then it became where
was like whoa she has all ours no I
could emotionally take it if my mom had
awful they mess why that's what the old
people homes are for right if it's for
grandparents is hilarious but it's
pretty fun when it's your own mom it's
tough my grandma was like I have a
boyfriend and I'm like who is it I
thought it was one of the old geezers
she was with it's just like that guy and
I'm like the worker because we had a
special moment and I'm like what
happened she goes he bathed me and I'm
all like what the [ __ ] that's what
they're supposed to do I guess for her
was sensual you know it was like
romantic especially we can't remember
why you're in there oh I picture her
saying all this while she has that
breathing her nose
can you imagine being that worker you'd
like just trying to your job and cleaner
and she's like getting all turned on do
all people are warning do they have
hands do old people have hands do you
think or they do they have hands it's
like they can see I mean
answer age I hate that age where your
hands go away
I thought you met as in like a box
laughs they did box in their yard I
don't give a box later so your final
person by that age if you guys are still
alive please shoot me if you have
Alzheimer's
oh man what's the point I mean unless
you guys can profit off of me and you're
like this videos yeah you need to sign
and exploit me I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah and we can do this if I'm
useless evidence by the time I'm usually
it's like if I can't give joy to the
world anymore and I'm just a bag of
[ __ ] potatoes shoot me like a
[ __ ] you don't want to eat
doodoo if it's for entertainment and I
want yeah I want to wrestle money to
your estate and then we keep the rest of
the money we're gonna save ain't right
Sophia but if we both have Alzheimer's
we could both fight over doodoo like
it's gold huh it'll be like your old Jay
casket so we'll make more room 5jk film
but you guys will think normal with
there you're actually your characters oh
there's just facility right here in
Downey where they're trying to do this
whole like top like era thing like to
help people with their long-term memory
for with Alzheimer's and all that and so
they'll have things of their youth like
thiefthief themed like restaurants and
all that nice time yeah and it's been
helping people with Alzheimer's like
remember things and their memories
improving and they're working their mind
and it's like when they're in an area
where they feel like familiar with like
the decor and that an era and the people
then it makes them use their mind to
like like I guess like activate some
part that helps them remember short-term
stuff they're not in an element where
they're like what the [ __ ] is this and
like half of their life is anxiety now
but then if they're in a comfortable
place and they're like yeah you know
what that said we're living in that time
for us then this is what we are
experiencing right now is that era for
us oh that whitter go back to yeah
what's gonna make us comfortable is to
think back to he was crazy like music
is hoarding all these 80s as oldies now
yeah 80s music as oldies that's
considered all these yeah it's not just
kinda considered eighties mm mm mm is 20
years ago yeah I could remember - 20
years ago in the 90s 50s music is as old
these rights less 40 years prior so 40
years ago was the eighties it's not
based on the technology of music that
classifies it I don't know I think of
the generations that have passed since
40 years ago III picture it's the music
like if it sounds like a old school
record then aa that's all these like you
can hear the crackling I don't think
like kid and you'll probably think
that's [ __ ] all this hell right it
sounds because it like to us maybe that
was like the equivalent of us here in
like um he's havin a 6 from bones we the
big maybe that's like the different era
yeah yeah that's beyond what he think
about back to the future
he only traveled 30 years back and he
was like oh [ __ ] this is different yeah
it'll be the 90s all right back to the
future travel back to the back to the
past today yeah 30 years that would be
1990 yeah it's crazy on my high school I
give you time with my high school they
have like some kid just back then
brought a video camera to school and was
filming like I feel like the 1980s or
1990s and it looks so [ __ ] weird
everyone was wearing those puffy jackets
everyone had bullets scrunchies big ol
scrunchie yeah it literally looked like
it was a movie they got a grease or
something and that says how everyone
dressed I was like well have you guys
seen on YouTube just like walkthroughs
of CDs and just some people upload
footage of like old [ __ ] black and
white interviews of Great Depression
people I never gotten that far back I
got sucked into one where they're
they're interviewing some some kid in
Boston in the 80s and thought gets it
[ __ ] trip everyone one of the cars
and but it's like just like voyeuristic
there's just some guy walking through
the streets and you really feel you know
like part of that light that's what
blogs are cool cuz people could actually
look back at least
much of our evidence now yeah and
YouTube
[Music]